Sometimes things do not go well,
that that's self evident,
but here's the rub.
Sometimes when things are not going
well,
it's precisely that which is most
valued.
That is the cause why?
It's because the world is revealed
through the template of your values.
If the world you are seeing is not the
world you want,
therefore it's time to examine your
values.
It's time to rid yourself of your
current presuppositions.
There's a famous experiment that I've
alluded to a couple of times I believe
in this lecture series,
the invisible gorilla experiment,
and in the invisible gorilla experiment,
there's two teams
of players,
each with three members,
one dressed in black and the other
dressed in white,
and each team is passing the basketball
back and forth to the team members and
milling about.
You'll see a video of them doing so.
They've basically filled the video
screen and the white team is passing a
basketball to the white team.
Members in the block team is passing a
basketball to the black team members and
your job as,
as far as the experimenters concerned,
is for you to count the number of times
that the black black team,
black team passes the basketball back
and forth.
So that's what you do.
So now you have an ambition and a name
and a value and the ambition and the aim
and the value.
They're all the same thing and that is
to perform well at the task.
Now the thing that's so cool about this,
and this is really so cool,
it's just unbelievably.
It's just unbelievable that this is the
case.
It's like a complete validation of of a
certain element of the Buddhist
worldview.
So they pass the ball for a couple of
minutes and then the experimenter says
to you,
how many?
And you say 15 and because you're happy
and you're happy with yourself because
you've been paying attention,
and then the experimenter says,
yeah,
that's right.
Or maybe not.
Maybe you missed one.
And then the experimenter says,
did you see the gorilla?
And half of you say,
what?
What?
What gorilla?
Like,
really?
And he and the experimenter says yes,
and then he rewinds it and plays the
video and like a minute and a half into
the three minute video,
sure enough,
in walks this guy in a gorilla suit,
six foot three or so stands in the
middle of the game,
right in the middle of the game,
the same size as the players,
perfectly obviously evident beats his
chest for like a second and a half and
then sorta saunders off and half the
people who watch the video don't see the
gorilla,
which is absolutely shocking.
And what that means is that your
ambitions blind you to the nature of
reality.
Now they eliminate some reality,
but they blind you to most of it and
that's fine because you're not.
There's not a lot of you.
In some ways,
you're very pinpoint thing like a laser
and so you just can't be attending to
everything all the time.
But one of the things that you might ask
yourself once you know that is that if
you're suffering dreadfully than one
possibility,
is that you're so fixed on the point.
You're so fixed on a point.
The fact that you're so fixed on the
point that you're fixed on might be
integrally related to why things are
going so catastrophic,
really wrong now,
perhaps not because you know there's a
lot of arbitrary ness about life and
perhaps you suffer even when you don't
deserve to.
That seems to happen in the book of job,
for example,
because job is a good guy and God has a
bet with Satan,
which seems like another relatively
nasty thing to do to let's say just
torture him and he does quite nicely to
see if he'll turn against God and it
seems like a rather playground sort of
thing for God to engage in.
But the point is is that even in a
document like the Old Testament,
there's ample suggestion that sometimes
people just get wiped out and hurt even
if they're living good moral lives,
aiming properly and all that.
There's an arbitrary agnes in life
that's not radical,
but it's possible that it's what you're
clinging to that's hurting you and it's
even possible.
That's the thing that you're clinging to
the hardest that's hurting you the most.
That could easily be someone you love
like lots of times I see people in
therapy and they're miserable for one
reason or another.
Sometimes it's because they have a very
close relationship with a family member
and that just isn't working.
You know the family member for the sake
of simplicity we'll say is not really
oriented towards helping them have a
good life.
The family member is instead oriented
towards making them as bloody miserable
as you can possibly make anyone and and
what would you say?
Exploiting the bond between family
members in order to enable that and then
sometimes the sacrifice that's necessary
is either merely distancing yourself
from that person,
sometimes substantively and sometimes
seriously distancing yourself from like
we don't talk anymore ever and so that's
pretty damn rough and it hurts and all
of that,
but,
but it's a good example of the fact that
sometimes in order to extract yourself
from the miserable bit of chaos that you
happen to be in meshed in.
You have to let go of what you love
best.
If the world you are seeing is not the
world you want,
therefore it's time to examine your
values are it's really worth.
It's really worth thinking about because
the alternative to is to curse fate,
right?
Because if it isn't you and there's
nothing you can do to change,
there isn't something you're doing
that's wrong.
Then it's faded itself.
It's the world itself.
It's other people let's say because
they're a huge part of the world or it's
the nature of the world itself or,
or it's God himself in whatever forum
you either believe in or don't believe
in because it's fundamentally all the
same in this sort of situation that I'm
describing.
So.
And one of the things that's really
interesting and I mentioned this before
about the Israelites in the Old
Testament,
is that they,
they got this right.
It's really something because what
happens to the Israelites over and over
in the Old Testament is that they get
all puffed up about how wonderful they
are,
and then they make moral errors because
they're arrogant and then God comes
along and just cuts them into pieces for
like generation after generation and
they wobbled back to their feet and they
always maintain the same attitude,
which is we did something wrong.
We did something wrong.
It's like,
it's like.
It's like an axiom rather than
observation is that if we're not,
if things are not laying themselves out
for us as they should be,
then we cannot curse God.
We have to look to ourselves while and
you think,
well,
why not curse?
God knows.
Maybe it's his fault.
That's a really good question and one of
the things that I've tried to figure out
over the last 30 years is,
well,
why not just curse God?
Because there is this arbitrary element
to existence and we are vulnerable and
there is plenty of suffering and things
are unfair.
Like there's problems,
right?
There's injustice and unfairness and all
of these things and an endless
suffering.
So why not just laid at the feet of God
and the whether God exists or not in
some sense,
by the way,
with regards to the metaphysics of this
particular discussion is not relevant.
It's the point remains the same either
way and the answer is as far as I can
tell that if you refuse to take on the
responsibility yourself and you
attempted to lay it at the feet of
either society or being itself,
then you instantly start to act in a way
that makes everything much worse,
not only for you but for everyone else
and maybe even for being itself and so
it's not helpful.
Now,
if you're.
If you decide that it's you,
you've got the problem.
Maybe that's not even true.
Like maybe you are someone who's being
tortured by the bet between God and
Satan and like too bad for you.
If that happens to be the case,
but it still seems to be the appropriate
thing for a human being who's standing
on his or her own two feet in a proper
manner to take the responsibility on for
themselves.
Regardless of the counter arguments that
might be made against,
that's really something.
It's time to rid yourself of your
current presuppositions.
I also think of that it's a deadwood
issue.
You know,
one of the things you see with motifs
like the pair of the Phoenix,
remember when Harry Potter goes off to
fight,
he's like St George.
He goes off to fight the hell is that
thing,
the basilisk that turns you to stone.
When you look at it to dragon,
for all intents and purposes,
it's guarding avert urgent.
What's her name for?
Not Virginia.
It's close to that though.
Jenny.
Jenny Ginevra,
right?
Which is a variant of virgin and very
introvert,
Virginia.
Well,
when he gets bitten by the,
by the dragon and poisoned,
that's the dragon of chaos,
right?
The thing that turns you to stone when
you look at it,
when he gets bitten by it,
then he's going to die and yeah.
Well,
if you get bitten by the thing that
turns you to stone when you look at it,
if it bites you,
man,
if you're not dead,
you're gonna wish you are.
It's one of the two.
And then the phoenix flies in and cries
tears into the wound and that heals
them.
And the Phoenix is the thing that allows
the dead wood to burn off occasionally,
let's say.
Well,
it's.
I think it's once every hundred years
with the Phoenix and of course it's
pretty dramatic.
The whole damn bird has to go up in
flames and then there's nothing left but
an egg.
But there's a very serious message there
too,
which is that you can compare yourself
in some sense to a forest fire,
to a forest in a forest,
has to burn now and then for the
deadwood to clear so that the forest can
actually maintain its continued
existence.
And if you stop the forest from burning
for a prolonged period of time,
which happened in the United States when
they were trying to manage the forest
fires too tightly,
then all that happens is the dead would
accumulate and accumulate and
accumulates and accumulates and
accumulates until the whole damn forest
is dead wood.
And then lightning hits it and it burned
so hot that it burns the topsoil off.
And then there's nothing left.
Nothing grows.
And so that's a good moral lesson,
which is don't wait too long to let the
dam did,
would burn off,
you know,
maybe a little self immolation on a
daily basis.
Might be preferable to burning yourself
all the way down to the bedrock once
every 20 years or so because maybe there
won't be anything left of you when you
do that.
And you know that happens to people all
the time.
I've seen that happen to people many,
many times.
The deadwood accumulates the mess around
them,
gathers the chaos that they haven't
dealt with accumulates.
And then one day the spark comes in and
they burned so far and so fast that
there's not enough left of them to
recover.
And then they're the people who've been
eaten by the beast there have been eaten
by the dragon and now we're inside its
belly.
Another very common architectural motif.
And while maybe a hero will come along
and rescue them or maybe they'll just
stay in there forever.
And that's a precursor to the idea of
hell.
And it's not something I would
recommend.
So a little medicine on a regular basis
is a lot better too.
Then total emulation on terms other than
your own sporadically.